thank you
[Music]
in Chinese news oh
engineers in China have irreparably
damaged the Great Wall of China while
trying to find a shortcut for their
business according to local reports
that's the most shiny [__] I've ever
heard bro shortcut
anybody know shortcuts too long man oh
that's so oh nobody use that anymore
us excavators were used to excavate the
original gap of the ancient Great Wall
into a large gap so that the excavator
could pass through the gap which caused
irreversible damage to the Integrity of
the mean great wall and the safety of
cultural relics so there was already a
hole and it go this already was looking
at it's like an eroded hole right yeah
like a small natural one I guess but
they just needed to make the Gap bigger
so they can get their [__] excavation
machines through it or this is an old
school like hey can you drive around I
don't want to drive around and drive
through yeah well dude driving around
probably completely sucks by the way
they have to go through Mongolia yeah
these guys um I saw a picture but
they're like there's a photo of them
locked up in handcuffs with like they
look like fugitives that got caught yeah
if you [__] with Chinese relics dude the
government's gonna [__] kill your ass
look at this
how many miles of wall are there bro
it's like you can't take a little hole
in the thing because yeah you can see it
from space it's [__] long yeah I
didn't get to go I want to go too I was
in Beijing and then right when we're
about to go we got scammed and my friend
was like I don't want to go anymore and
I was like me neither
it's fun to be there I've been there I
think like twice now I wouldn't know
because I got Jack before we got there
okay you got Bluff he's coming back on
him about it you can't even walk across
like in one day huh like it's a crazy
line no way dude it's the gray wall of
China it's like [__] seven thousand
miles or something it's from like
California to New York is it like that
that's what I'm saying you take dig a
little hole in a big [__] yeah it's
13 000 miles that's insane oh my God 13
000 miles of like when [__] are like
you don't need that big truck you
probably got a little [__] dick that
[__] you don't need that big a wall dude
or something because I got small things
how many miles is from California New
York isn't it like three thousand that's
it yeah I think it's like five
wait how's the Great Wall that long 13
000 2900 miles around they went on
California to New York is 2914 miles
we're talking about 13
000. damn Jesus Christ so it's like four
four or five times they're counting like
because it winds and stuff doesn't it
yeah I mean if you could see it from a
space yeah dude that's pretty [__]
will you dig a little tiny hole everyone
flips the [__] up it was built when in
like 1830 something it took a long time
it was uh for being McDonald's no it's
okay all I know is it opens at 9am
um I think I think it took like several
times 20 BC wait what oh that was 18 18
45 1845 huh Ryan I'm off by like [__]
the whole Jurassic world dude wait say
that again 220 BC 220 BC but I think
they they've been building it for like
four dynasties or some [__]
yeah what was I even thinking that's
like 1891 so like when Marty went back
to see Doc in the old west but you know
what's funny though it still didn't keep
the Mongolians out they still won
yeah there was a there was a Chinese
Trump back in the day they're like we
gonna Emperor Trump they were like we're
gonna build a big wall tell those
Mongolian [__] you make a pay for it and
then make them pay for it so how did the
Mongolians get over the wall they went
around grappling hooks all of them 13
000 miles through the animation yeah
dude dude probably they couldn't guard
13 000 miles away you crazy yeah dude
are you girdle that they couldn't like
the [__] Fire fast enough the signals
remember Mulan that's how they got got
the signals did get lit though that was
yeah but it wasn't fast enough but the
thing is if the whole point was to keep
the Mongolians out they took their sweet
ass time building issue that's true what
were the Mongolians doing and [__]
off the whole time but to be fair the
Mongolians were really good at like just
mercking everyone's had their day bro I
think Mongolians went all the way toward
Europe first because they were following
the wall they're like man this wall is
so long man and then they went all the
way to Europe and then they're like okay
come down this way oh wait is it the
same thing if we're saying Mongols and
Mongolians is that the same yeah okay
there were the Mongol the Mongol the
golden horde Genghis Khan Genghis Khan
baby
I like that I like that Genghis come is
there any relationship spray come all
over oh yeah you know how like we have
the word [__] is that in any way
related to like just dissing the Mongols
forever no I think [__] was
supposed to be East Asians oh damn so is
it this on just Asians no it says uh
[__] in the dictionary is an
old-fashioned term for a person with
Down Syndrome oh never mind yeah
they thought that Chinese people looked
like down syndrome that's what they
thought but was it like was it created
they make the word [__] after how
they felt like Mongolians like looked
kind
yeah I could I could picture in a Roman
looking at a Mongol and going down scene
okay maybe I need to spell it with like
an H or some [__] like that
[__] m-o-n-g-o-l is an old-fashioned
term for a person with Down Syndrome uh
and then in the related questions is
Genghis Khan a Mongol Genghis Khan also
spelled originally is very you in there
Golian Warrior ruler one of them no it
doesn't say anything about it
so you know that biker gang called the
Mongols yeah yeah of course did they
meant to be a crew of down syndrome guys
obviously
that's a bad diss well I don't know I
just the term is wrong they're very
close to this area I think the
difference is Mongol it spelled the same
way but if you put a capital M making it
like a proper noun then you're talking
about the Mongolian people of that area
I like that one better versus a
lowercase Mongol let's dig in on this
topic what about ghoul what is a ghoul
like who's like a spooky Villain Like A
mongool
it's a very important conversation
that's for sure is dude everyone thinks
it's [__]
we brought this up yesterday and uh
Steve Green over here said he he backs
these uh these vanders
how big you gotta have your [__]
world Wonder to be dude this guy's just
trying to get to work
he's [__] just trying to make his job
a little easier what's the American
equivalent of this crime like what's
something that we have here that people
would all be mad about like Mount
Rushmore or something I don't want to
[__] let down by the way that's
somebody someone shortcut is through
Mount Russian I've never seen it before
that's what I'm saying what do all
Americans care about do you even care
about the same things not really no not
these days we have the Statue of Liberty
somebody [__] up the Statue of Liberty
cry yeah maybe I'll say that every
actually every time someone [__] with
the Hollywood Boulevard rainbow Street
people get pissed I know you're talking
about people people burning out burnouts
on it there's like a oh really there's
like the pride Street they do takeovers
over there do we have anything old
enough
I don't have anything old enough that's
like a relic that's like the Liberty
button I think the statue
on the East Coast Statue of Liberty
Liberty is not as old as a Liberty Bell
but it's like yeah more symbolic I guess
but the Statue of Liberty was given to
us at the same time as a you know Great
Wall was built in 1800s you have 1855.
what about the pair pyramids to the
Egyptians would that be like the yeah
for sure oh that's like a one-to-one
actually you know what's funny arguably
Americans probably be more pissed for
things getting [__] abroad oh that's
true especially the white women but the
same irony is that those people that are
[__] the stuff abroad are probably
Americans true
but in this case China on China crime
what were they trying to do shortcut
business no but what's the goal like to
excavate they're like what are they
doing no they wanted a elevator yeah no
it's like a shortcut as in like they
need to go through so then they could
get to the other side of the of the town
like it's like um they're just trying to
open up a space so they can drive
through it to do what oh just to to save
space so they don't have to I mean to to
not waste time to go around and [__] to
be like a Panama Canal like you could
just go through just a great wall trying
to have any military value now or is it
just completely a tourist tourist thing
but I heard that a lot of it is like
deteriorating yeah like uh some of it
huge parts of it is like it's not kept
up because they can't it says that only
eight percent of the Wall constructed
during the Ming Dynasty which is the
last Dynasty to contribute to the Great
Wall remains in good condition while the
rest has fallen into disrepair with a
third of the structure having completely
Fallen apart here's the funnier part uh
local farmers and Builders have even
taken bricks and stones to use in their
own personal projects [__] yeah damn I
got a mug I got a mug made out of the
Berlin Wall it's pretty cool a mug yeah
I peed on the Berlin Wall at some bar in
Vegas they have like a urinal made out
of the Berlin Wall there's pieces of
Berlin Wall everywhere man yeah
if you go to Germany you could buy mugs
and then there's like uh ones that have
a little piece of the burger oh that's
pretty cool did you guys see how like
some dude at the Coliseum was like
etching him and his girl's name into the
side of it yeah oh my god do we talk
about it yeah the real Coliseum right
[__] yeah you can't do that they should
feed him to a bear yeah do you show us
the Coliseum anymore
dude did you see Russell Crowe brought
his family to the Coliseum and said I
showed him where I used to work that's
funny it's brilliant they're doing a
sequel today
yeah I love that movie really is it with
him yeah with him I [__] love
Gladiator I hope that now I hope I hope
they don't use a a Asian nine bit
non-binary person to be the actual
Gladiator Asian yeah
I hope they do now it's Asian non-binary
yeah
foreign